hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up today
is that just continue to search for
survivors in Florida as 87 people are
confirmed dead after Hurricane Ian
struck the U.S
Brazilians will vote for a second time
in their general election we'll take a
look at what it means for the Amazon
rainforest
and with the Tory Party Conference
kicking off today how do their
environmental policies compare to labor
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes happening to our world and
interrogate some of the potential
solutions to The Climate crisis or we
start in America where at least 87
people are known to have died after
Hurricane Ian struck the U.S we've
rescue teams still searching for
survivors among the ruins of flooded
homes now the cleanup is now underway
after the hurricane tore through Florida
and South Carolina after it had of
course hit the islands of Cuba and
Puerto Rico or President Joe Biden will
see the disaster recovery efforts for
himself when he visits Puerto Rico later
today and Florida on Wednesday now
according to Florida State's officials
approximately 10 000 people remain
unaccounted for although the authorities
believe many are likely to be in
shelters or without power
now a massive cleanup efforts is now
underway and the latest figures suggest
that more than 1.1 million residents are
still without power and Wi-Fi now
according to the American Red Cross more
than 1 300 disaster workers are
supporting relief efforts that's across
five states for NBC's Chris poloney is
in Fort Myers Beach in Florida and he
sent this report
Leah this long line of cars is coming to
a checkpoint at Fort Myers Beach most of
them are being turned away if they're
residents the only people that are being
allowed through are search and rescue
teams and other First Responders that's
because officials here want to focus on
search and Recovery only and they feel
that letting too many people down to the
beach area would hinder that effort over
the weekend search teams rescued about 2
000 people in 150 pets bringing them to
safety all throughout the areas affected
by this hurricane and those searches
started again at daylight this morning
there is good news when it comes to the
power outages here 600 000 people in
Florida still without power that's down
from 2.6 million so they're making quick
work of the power grid however in the
hardest State areas it could be weeks
before they get power back on because
the grid will have to be rebuilt NBC
News has confirmed at least 87 deaths
from this storm four in the Carolinas
and the rest here in the state of
Florida
the search and rescue efforts continue
all throughout the area but this is not
just a coastal problem this storm cut a
path of Destruction across the entire
Florida Peninsula and so Inland many
communities are suffering from River in
stream flooding because of all the rain
that fell from Ian and so now a lot of
those communities are still watching
flood waters rise and so rescue efforts
are going on there the governor of
Florida said there is some good news
however Pine Island one of the barrier
islands here that was cut off from the
mainland because the road was damaged
the governor says that a temporary Road
might be in place by this weekend Leah
back to you
many thanks to Chris and the team there
now Brazilians will vote for a second
time in their general election after
neither of the leading candidates
secured a majority of the vote now the
candidates former president Lula de
Silva and current President Joe
bolsonaro are divided on a number of
issues but none more than the future of
the Amazon
rainforests well the Amazon rainforest
plays a major role in maintaining the
global and Regional climates and the
Amazon it soaks up doesn't it one-fourth
of CO2 absorbed by all land on Earth now
the amount absorbed today though is less
than 30 percent than it was in the 1990s
and that's because of deforestation now
the latest projection suggests but by
the year 2050 temperatures in the Amazon
will increase by two to three degrees
Celsius which could result in longer and
more severe droughts along with
substantial changes in seasonality now
the two candidates in the Brazilian
election have different outlooks on the
Amazon so according to the environmental
charity while since John bolsonaro
became president deforestation has
increased by 70 that's over three years
and 900 000 hectares of Amazon
rainforests have been burned in the past
year and in the month to 26th of
September fires in the rainforest soared
to their highest levels in a decade with
36
850 fire alerts in the region now in
comparison his rival Lula de Silva has
pledged to preserve the Amazon and said
the global crisis would be an absolute
priority during his seven-year
presidency from 2003 deforestation
dropped about 65 percent uh in Brazil
That's according to Brazil's National
Institute for space Research into silver
has also promised to create a Ministry
for indigenous peoples our chief
correspondent Stuart Ramsey has the
latest on a country divided
bolsonaro supporters are always said
that the polls were wrong they're not
necessarily wrong it's just that some of
the votes for other candidates have
actually gone to bolsonaro Robin
Tallulah
I think one of the concerns for many
people though is as in this Gap we now
have between the rounds is where the
Electoral violence could increase we
know there has been some already and it
could be pretty volatile there's a sort
of real sense of how this country is
it's really divided I mean virtually in
half
the Luna supporters are convinced that
they will win in the second round and
they deny that bolsonaro's team will
feel that they've got some momentum with
them but
the polling had shown that bolsonaro is
nowhere near getting through and of
course he actually is very close indeed
everything to fight for still for both
sides
disappointment here but I suppose
this Beluga supporters
have another go at it and they're
convinced they will win in that second
round
okay let's take a look at some of the
day's other climate news now for you and
the World Bank has agreed to provide
Egypt with 400 million dollars to
develop sustainable infrastructure and
lower carbon emissions in the
transportation sector this all comes
ahead of the country hosting the cop 27
climate Summit which is happening next
month
here in Palace has confirmed that King
Charles will not attend the cop 27
climate conference so that's despite his
passionate commitment to environmental
issues it was responding wasn't it to a
story in the Sunday Times which claimed
prime minister Liz truss had ordered the
king not to attend the palace said
advice had been sourced by the kin and
given by mistrust
fleeks from Nordstrom pipelines have now
stopped after ruptures were discovered
in the natural gas lines last week
according to the Danish energy agency
now the agency said a stable pressure
now appears to have been achieved on the
pipelines meaning gas is no longer
flowing out of them
I think lamb restoration targets are to
be tripled in Wales in an attempt to
boost biodiversity all comes after an
expert review commission by the Welsh
government looks at ways to tackle
nature loss in the country
the Farmers Union has warned the
Christmas turkey supplies could be at
risk if the worst Aviation outbreak in
UK history continues to spread more than
3 million birds have had to be cold so
far with the disease detected at 155
sites across the UK
now the Conservative Party Conference
has got underway in Birmingham and in
the next hour the chancellor is expected
to give her speech backing his new
growth plan and after Labor's conference
focused on a Greener future will there
be any room for environmental policies
in the Tories plans well I think it's a
good time to check in with our chief
political correspondent John Craig he's
uh live at the Tory Party Conference
um so John been a busy day for the Tory
party but can we expect more green
issues to be front and center of their
conference
voted recently to minister of State at
Northern Ireland uh the uh were probably
best known for his views on brexit uh he
founded something called The Net Zero
scrutiny group now to Fringe meeting
this morning
um organized by the right-wing Think
Tank The Institute of economic Affairs
uh Mr it was entitled can the UK afford
Net Zero Mr Baker said the answer was no
in the short term he said that uh
cutting Net Zero commitments this year
would save households more than fifteen
hundred pounds amid the current energy
crisis he was slapped down however by a
fellow conservative MP that was Bim
afalami who said we can't afford to uh
not to meet our Net Zero Target which is
20 50. and so that was a class that
happened this morning
after the chancellor speaks here this
afternoon we are going to hear the debut
if you like of the new environment
secretary that is ranel Jaya wardener
now during the Tory leadership hustings
Liz truss was asked a number of times
about the record of water companies both
leaks and also the pumping of sewage
into rivers and the Sea and it's quite
likely that we're going to hear
something from the new defrost secretary
about clamping down on that perhaps
tougher fines for those water companies
that pump our sewage into the sea that's
coming up in after the chancellor speaks
a little bit later on just on the Prince
Charles Rao at number 10 have hit back
at the suggestion that Liz truss advised
the king to stay away from the cop 27
climate Summit
number 10 have said today are they not
going to get into conversations between
the Prime Minister and the king I think
I might have said Prince Charles I mean
they go King Charles
um we have a proud record
um uh when it comes to cop we're forging
ahead with our plans for Net Zero we'll
continue to deliver on those promises
asked if the PM believes there should be
a member of the royal family giving a
message to the summit that's a decision
for the royal family any suggestion the
PM would tell the king not to do
something is ridiculous and would not
happen said number 10 today okay John
thank you very much covered all bases
there for us and finally quality street
is axing its famous Sprite plastic
wrapping on its chocolates to make them
more environmentally friendly now nearly
2 million rappers from the Suites end up
in landfill every year and the company
we now replace the plastic wrapping with
a vegetable base wax now the change is
expected to be made in time for
Christmas